hello again how you guys doing all right
so quickly um
i've got three sources for you that
uh it's an exposition of the evidences
that relate to the debate that was the
apus
where he obliterated himself where
humiliated himself
where he decimated himself annihilated
himself finished
himself because he's a man with
multi-layered self-delusion he's a man
with
the with delusions of grandeur he's a
man who's unaccomplished
in every sphere of life
but moving on now communication is done
self humiliation has been complete
moving on the point i wanted to make is
just this is just a discussion about the
exposition of some of the evidences i
put forward
so one evidence i talked about is ibn
moneda about the authority of the earth
of the roundness of the earth
of the early times now if you look at
the first tweet that i've put in the
comment section also description box
below
you'll find here the reference to ibn
moneta where he says that actually the
majority of scholars of his time
um said that the earth was round okay
and he was at the time of ahmedabad and
habilis the company was not a terabyte
by the way that was a mistake but he
still loved the seraph
so he was still in you know the first
300 years of the prophet muhammed
obviously 241 he died three three five
so he was of the salaf and he did say uh
about the returning of the earth
the second thing we talked about is in
chapter 25 verse number 61
i made the claim that there's two ways
of reading this which means
uh sun that that allah created all of
these things the constellations and so
on and then he said the sun
and the moon so there's one as we know
there's
multiple ways of reciting the quran and
all of them are harmonious and
complementary
not uh con contradictory
and unharmonious so the the second way
which is as you can see here underneath
in the description box in the second
tweet
uh is surojan sologen is the plural of
the word sirajan and siraj means
sun so the plural is many sons which is
in line with the general 21st century
cosmological picture and i'm saying
that that's the only interpretation
maybe you can interpret it as stars no
problem the idea
is it's definitely linguistically uh
facilitated that you can say that these
are many sons why because it's the
plural
it's the plural of the word all right so
we said
number one is quote
first tweet second tweet the son and the
general thing i'm saying is that the
quran is applicable for the seventh
century
and for 21st century i'm not saying that
it's not a bold concordance claim
that the quran is saying things it's
acting like a scientific textbook and so
on
i'm just saying it's harmonious with
with the 7th century 21st century and
everything between
so that was the claim i'm making you
can't use science to just prove the
quran
for reasons related to this but also to
the philosophy of science the fact that
science is not
incorrigible except for that it's
something which is not meant to produce
a set of eternal truths in that sense
so that's the first argument the second
thing i talked about was the
if you look at the third tweet below one
second
here it's very important to talk up to
to mention that we're not talking about
them
us the us it's very clear
we're not talking about the default
hokum the penal or the had punishment
applied to the
more ted we're not we're not talking
about this we are talking about the fact
that the prophet muhammed
in the treaty of hodeidah he was
conditioned
yes to not return any more ted
that goes to them he was conditioned
to not return any more ted that goes
uh to the disbelieving lands and he
accepted that condition
so what my point was is that this sets a
precedent okay this sets a precedent
now the question uh could be asked well
is this
only those who are there okay and they
don't have to be returned or does it
include those on the way and those who
are
going there well either way
if if we accept a which is those who are
there don't need to be returned back and
the head doesn't need to be
done that's a werjip a word of action
which has been made
which has been suspended by the by the
contract right
so if if one word can be mata of the
contract
then the question is why can't we extend
that word even if you don't accept the
fact
even if you want to say that the nos is
not clear the the the
text is not clear about those who are
there and those who are on the way
but the point is the principle is in
place that
a had can be suspended a hat can be
suspended
yeah a penal law can be a suspended
based on
uh based on what based on the fact
that there is in the contract
condition in the contract and it's not a
battle shot it's not a false shot it's
the contract still stands you see this
is the thumbnail this is the fruit that
we get from that
now someone may uh disagree with this
and i know there are disagreements in
the scholarly circles
i know hasn't had a completely different
opinion to this he said this is only
applicable to the prophet
sallam and so on there is definitely
difference of opinion scope of opinion
here but this is the opinion
uh that i follow this is the opinion
that i follow i think this is the
the best opinion and also not only that
but the most reasonable one for our
times especially considering the fact
that there's an american hegemonic power
and
we have to understand with the american
hegemonic power
and what do you think you can do what do
you think you can do honestly as a
muslim nation like brunei
or something like this you can't do much
so it's actually it's a necessity anyway
i mean this is
a point of necessity and as we know in
us
the the necessities allows that which is
otherwise not allowed anyway i mean
otherwise not allowed anyways
is to be measured with its appropriate
level of measurement in other words
you don't go overboard you do as much as
you need to do
but this clearly in the 21st century
where
someone might say um someone might say
well
how how is this sharia i mean to be
implemented really on the state level on
on the on the level of the state we when
really
we're considering the heterogenic power
of the america uh america and the west
and so on
what i'm saying is that there's there's
room for compromise and this is the
point guys listen carefully
the reason why the prophet muhammad was
who he was
because he knew when to fight and he
knew when to compromise
and not only who when to fight and when
to compromise
how to fight and how to compromise and
with whom to fight and with whom to
compromise
if you know in life who to fight how to
fight
and when to fight how to compromise
with whom to compromise and how to
compromise you will be successful
that's why even from a secular paradigm
even from a secular paradigm yeah
you have to admit that the prophet
muhammad
has become a cliche now like heart put
him as number one one of the most
influential people in the world
uh but the point is you have to admit
that he was militarily successful you
have to admit that
he was absolutely militaristic and why
was he militarily successful
because he made the right decisions you
can't be a military success
by making frivolous and capricious and
uh
arbitrary ad hoc type decisions you
can't
and so that when the shire allows all of
these things that we've just mentioned
al hadith yeah
upon us as muslims actually yeah to
present the sharia with the full scope
of those nuances because when someone
says for example
well what you know would you want this
killing of apostates in these
look we're talking about 21st century if
the prophet saw sallam within the span
of his own life
was able to make compromises yes he was
able to make compromises
subhanallah on such issues on such
issues
why are we we're 21st century we can't
even use the scope of
the jewish potential maneuverability to
make such compromises as well and this
is clearly in the deen
so uh we have to remember we're living
in a time of necessity we are living in
a time of
and the deen came to protect five things
okay the five things that the deen came
to protect is the deen
you know sorry the dean uh the the the
the the neff's
the mel and the the religion
the deen came to protect the religion
the
the the the the self human human self
yeah the wealth of the individuals
the um
the intelligence of the individual and
finally they are the honorable
individual
so we always have to assess these five
things yeah in conjunction with what
we're doing
it's not always are you bring a hadith
you have to bring a hadith in the
context of what the life
what's the point what's the point of you
bringing me a hadith
what's the point of you bringing me to
the hadith actually there's context
to that hadith and there's other hadith
and there's other situations what's the
point of you bringing me the hadith
whoever changed the deen that's killed
them yeah the hadith is there
and if it's not it luck because if it's
islam then whoever comes muslim is
killed as well so clearly you have to
understand the hadith
yeah because if it was general then
whoever whoever changes his religion
meaning
a christian become muslim you're gonna
kill him clearly there's context behind
it and that's why you have to understand
these con
these these things uh in the and when
we're given answers we have to be
measured
listen we have to be measured yeah
because these people are looking for
some
wild answer that make us look backward
and make islam look at an impossible
religion for the 21st century which
isn't
because we have usual fit we have
parameters we have kawaii and so on and
so forth
and so with that i leave the evidences
and i put also something of ibm
where he mentions that the the the the
the treaty that you can put in place
which means it can be uh up until
whatever you like it's not just like or
someone could say it's time bound
it's not time bound in hajj himself says
it can continue for
uh forever so i've done that in 10
minutes uh check the tweets out if you
understand if you don't but i've put all
the sources there
and clearly we're not so we're not
trying to reinvent something we're not
trying to reinvent something
this is all within the deen all within
the framework and that's what people
have to understand
and in fact one more thing i want to
leave with you a shout out be mentioned
that
when you have kawaii yeah
is actually more heavy than hadith
because kawaii is made up of many
different hadith in quran
so when i say that
times of necessity allows that which is
that's deeper and more of an evidence
then you bring in single hadith because
it's made up of many different hadiths
many of the evidences
that's how you have to think now you
can't just think oh hadith you have to
think
hawaii principles principles principles
and
then the hadith come the hadith make up
all them make up the principle rather
than
the opposite and so the principles are
in many according to be
even even more powerful than the hadith
because they're made up of many of them